you're hearing from all these  right-wingers about the trump mar-a-lago  fbi raid if it could happen to trump  then it could happen to you and it could  happen to anyone well that's not really  a very good argument against what  happened if what they seem to be saying  is what they actually are saying which  is nobody is  immune  from being  prosecuted  uh having a search warrant served  against you whatever that's a good thing  we know it can happen to all of us it  happens all the time to people that are  outside of the top echelons  it's a good thing that it can also  happen to people in trump's position of  power it's not the strong talking point  they think it is